Dude, tell me about a deal that you've done,
a pitch you've been on, a Zoom close that you didn't close
and what the business owner said.
All right, so just so you know,
I've had five Zoom closes and I'm closed four of those.
So it's just been one.
Hey, all flex, all flex.
I like it, I like it.
Bro, you said you have to flex, so why not?
Dude, I love it, bro.
I wanna see more fucking posts is what I'm saying.
Let's go.
For sure, dude.
Hey, hit me though.
Hit me with the one you didn't close.
The one that I lost was,
they told me at the end of the call
that they had to talk to their spouse.
Okay.
And so I gave them until the next day,
until like around noon.
And then I called them, didn't answer.
And then we started going this back and forth
where he would shoot me a text.
He's like, yeah, call me later, blah, blah, blah.
I would call him and it didn't happen.
And I just ended up getting another business owner
and closing him.
So, but yeah, he just never got back to me.
So that one, was it the spouse or partner
or was the spouse a partner?
Or was like spouse partner or spouse spouse?
Like not involved in the business.
Spouse, spouse.
Yeah, that's a tough one because,
dude, the thing with those is like,
this is the pitch that they got, right?
So he got the phone with you.
He goes to his wife and he goes,
hey honey, there's this guy, he's in North Carolina.
He wants to do leads and it's 1500 bucks a month flat rate.
She's like, fuck no.
She has no involvement in the business.
She wasn't on the call, so you're fucked, right?
So the only thing I would say,
like this is an easy one in the sense that like,
you just gotta make sure upfront that you let them know
that if there's a decision maker
that needs to be on the call other than them
to get them on the call, okay?
Yeah.
That's the only way.
Cause dude, overcoming that shit is really difficult
because like that person doesn't even know
what's going on in the business anyway.
Makes sense?
So here's one thing that I've been doing
and a lot of you guys, I think even probably you,
do you remember the video I sent you
before we jumped on the call?
Yeah, that's what I've been doing.
Like when I send over the screencast right when I end it,
I say, you know, just make sure if there's anybody else
that has to be on the call, bring them on.
That's what I say.
And since then I've had no issues with that objection
or it hasn't come up.
So you did, you started doing that after you lost that deal.
Correct.
That's beautiful.
So all of you guys that are on,
all of you guys that are listening,
that's something I do and I'm showing you an example.
Like the thing is, I know if you're jumping on the call
to talk about FFM, it's probably a good fit.
Like you've seen the videos, you want to grow,
but guess what?
People get weird, people get nervous,
people do all these things.
So I don't want that to be an objection.
So I send that video out and you guys know,
I kind of made an over exaggeration
if you need to bring your dog, your goldfish,
your spouse or Jesus, bring them to the call
because I ain't doing, I want to think about it bullshit.
So you can say it a lot less confrontational,
but nonetheless, it's the same concept.
So I like that weaving it into the pre-closed screencast
is brilliant, dude.
I love that.
It's exactly what I do.
And it's also part of the training.
It's like, the other thing too,
is while you're doing the calls and the leads,
you could also, hey, so is it just you
or is it your partner?
Like, do you have a partner?
Is your spouse involved?
But I would definitely say,
is there anyone else that needs to be involved
like in this decision?
And you can, instead of being like,
making it like a lot of buying pressure,
just say, look, man, I don't want to play telephone
where I tell you everything.
You got to go to your wife or your partner
and then half of it's missing.
And then it's like,
I don't want to have to pitch this twice.
So get them on the call.
And literally when you jump on, say, hey, so we're good.
Like there's no one else who needs to be on this call.
Okay, cool.
And if they say, yes, cool, we're rescheduling this bitch
because I ain't going to do this twice.
But dude, it sounds like you already knew the answer
but I'm really glad you came on to tell everyone.
And that's definitely something you guys
should be incorporating at the end of your Zoom close
or your screencast just to mention,
hey, if there's anybody else, get them on the call.
And if that means we need to reschedule, I'm okay with it
but it's going to be way more beneficial for both of us
to get them on the call.
Yeah, can I say one last thing before I get off?
Please, please, please.
So usually what I've done and I did the same thing
with that person that I lost the deal with
was when I'm sending over the leads,
whenever I get on the phone with them
and I feel like they're not that busy
and they have a couple of minutes to talk
and I ask them all the questions about your closing rate,
your profit margin, right there I incorporate that question
of like, are you the sole decision maker?
Do you have like any other partners or whatever?
And so with that person, I did the same
but I didn't bring it up on the screencast, right?
And last thing I'll say, dude,
is I couldn't agree more with you
when it comes to the entire setup.
And the reason why I say that was
the last deal that I closed, this guy has a partner.
They run a concrete company.
They do about $3 million a year.
So he obviously has partners and nobody came on the call.
It was just him.
And it was the easiest sale of my life.
And why?
Because of the setup, because I did it properly.
So as long as you do the setup correctly,
you're gonna get the deal, man.
So that's what I wanted to say.